I thought we'd have a look at some of
the shortest papers they've ever been
written one of the sort of most famous
ones was this one here by lambda and
parking which you can literally see look
how short is virtually nothing there but
the contents really good because it
actually disproves a very long-standing
conjecture that it held for for hundreds
of years
so they were just just proving with an
actual example exactly we're disproving
the the Euler conjecture and what is the
Euler conjecture well it's it's kind of
related to fear much less theorem
Fermat's theorem what does it say you've
got two numbers a 1 to 6 to the K plus a
2 to the K equals B to the K and they're
basic it says there are no integer
solutions for K greater than 2 okay
that's for MLS theorem what's all this
conjecture it's a generalization of this
it basically you just take n of these
guys and again now you're saying all
this conjecture would be there are no
interest integer solutions for K greater
than n now integer solutions for K
greater than n so of course fermat's
last theorem was the case of N equals 2
this is the general case right but this
is not true right this paper proves it
right basically in this example and is 4
but K is 5 disproven there you go so in
a nutshell did this prove but this
doesn't have the record anymore I don't
have ever did up the record it's sort of
a classic short paper that achieves
quite a lot their record is a I think
currently held by this paper by your
friend John Conway somebody called Alex
sofa I think it isn't that's how you
pronounce it ok so the app they ask a
question in the tail so I think that's a
bit of a cheat and then err so they're
basically asking about how many trying
how many equilateral triangles you need
to cover an equilateral triangle of a
given size so basically the paper just
says N squared plus 2 can and then it
has a picture of their solution so it's
kind of like got two words in it right
the add the following question right so
you take an equilateral triangle and you
imagine it it's got a length of side end
and then you could ask well how many
triangles of side one you know so unit
side triangles equilateral triangles do
I need to fill it to cover it well you
know the answer it turns out to be N
squared it's quite easy to see that show
you by example if you've got side - so
we've got side - you know we can
fill it with four equilateral triangles
like that so these are all got side 1
and they felt but four of them fairly
equal uh triangle of side 2 which is 2
squared which is 2 squared exactly right
and it generalizes in it the answer is N
squared for waterside and ok so what
these guys wanted to know is what if we
make it a little bit bigger than n
naught n plus 1 but but just a little
bit bigger than n so n plus Epsilon I
mean you need them
ok so you might think I know I'm going
to need more than N squared because I've
gone N squared would cover the original
one right but so I'm going to need more
than that so I'm going to need at least
n squared plus 1 so they were asking all
can you do with N squared plus 1 and
they didn't actually answer the question
they say actually you need n squared
plus 2 how do they show that well what
you do is you sort of stop it at n minus
1 so you draw consider n minus 1 there
ok and then you've got a little bit
there of 1 plus epsilon to go little
every 1 plus epsilon bit there ok now
this thing this bit bit in here is going
to need n minus 1 squared to fill it ok
now what they do is they say right what
do I need to fill this a little bit left
over here well the way they do it is you
know this has got length m plus Epsilon
that way ok so you squeeze in it can't
you can't you're not going to cover
these edges with n edges of the triangle
right you're going to need a least n
plus 1 okay so you squeeze in n plus 1
of them okay like so maybe overlapping
they definitely have to overlap right
because M plus of Shiloh there's n plus
a tiny bit okay and you're going to
squeeze it n plus one of them so they're
definitely going to overlap so you get n
plus 1 of them there ok and you fill in
the top bits ok and to fill in the top
bits so on and so forth you need another
n ok and then you can do it
so how much have you got total now in
total you've got n minus 1 squared plus
n plus n plus one okay if you work out
what that is this is N squared minus 2n
plus 1 plus 2n plus 1 which is N squared
plus 2 the extra but you know it could
be less than two they're showing yeah so
this is what I think about it I don't
think they even answer the question the
question is can N squared plus 1 unit
equilateral triangles cover an
equilateral triangle side M plus Epsilon
they just say they don't say yes or no
they just say N squared plus two can so
maybe they could have said maybe that's
better answer the question if you look
in other fields there is shorter ones
though right I mean I found some of this
this this one there's not it's not math
but the is in the applied behavior
analysis it's your successful self
treatment of a case of writer's block
causes there's nothing there there's
another one
you know comprehensive overview of
chemical free consumer products this is
in chemistry chemistry journal and there
aren't any actually this didn't just
didn't appear in the journal they said
that they didn't publish it but they did
include it for amusement purposes
there's plenty of short papers out there
there's there's also short abstracts
there's another thing you can you can
look at this is one that caught my
attention this is a physics one can the
apparent superluminal neutrino speeds be
explained as a week as a quantum week
measurements and it's there's a classic
thing in in in you know within academia
that if you up I feel title has a
question mark at the end of it then the
answers probably probably not and indeed
their abstract is probably not I would
actually say definitely that because we
now know that there are no faster than
light neutrinos that that was just a
screwed up experiment there's an even
shorter I've shot there this is no
longer the question it is the sequence
of earthquakes in Southern California
with aftershocks removed poissonian so
this is a lot of mixture of
mass and I guess geography but the
answer isn't probably not it yes so that
sort of goes against the the usual rules
of the game and but this is all it's
just a bit of fun right but I think
what's more what would be bear is right
it's not so much how short the paper is
but in a way impact per word okay so
short paper that
chief Dalat okay now I this is clearly
open to debate but I think that
candidate for this is this bad boy by
the beautiful Matt John Nash so this is
a very very short paper which it starts
there and it finishes there okay so it's
a page long and this basically started
off game theory this this is really you
know one of the main papers underlying
economics he basically ultimately won
the Nobel Prize for economics for this
paper and other ideas related to it and
so I think in terms of impact per word
this is probably the winner John Nash's
thesis is famously short as well I've
got a copy of his thesis here
non-corporate says of course it's about
game theory non-corporate Civ games it's
only like twenty six pages long like wow
you know I mean this this this thesis
won a Nobel Prize and it's 26 pages long
this is sort of a a bit of an urban myth
if you do must agree as I did and
there's an urban myth that goes around
the students as to there's this Harper
as this PhD thesis that someone did once
and it's like a page long and it proved
some result from that hadn't been known
for a hundred years of years and it just
did it in one page and there you go bang
PhD thesis came out I think that is a
myth but I would love it if somebody
father found that out that it wasn't
I've had a little digging around and I
don't think is I think it serves of
short short theses big impact you do
well to be good old John Nash
this episode has been supported by
audible.com
and if you've got some reading to catch
up on an audiobook is a great way to do
it
among audibles vast collection of titles
is the acclaimed book A Beautiful Mind
the biography of John Nash who we've
just been discussing it's written by
Sylvia Nasar
or if biographies aren't your thing but
you still want something with bit of a
math twist I also highly recommend the
humans a novel by Matt Hagen one of my
favorite stories of the last few years
but whatever the sort of thing you like
I can guarantee audibles going to have
it and you can also get started with a
free 30-day trial by going to
audible.com
really excellent features like whisper
sync for voice so you can synchronize
your audiobook and Kindle without losing
your place and if you do give that free
30-day trial ago make sure you use the
address audible.com slash numberphile
just so they know you came from the
channel here
[Music]